oui
[Musique]
les diamants les stars les mannequins
les égéries la planète balle continue de
tourner même avec moins d'exposants mais
derrière les paillettes et la guerre de
l'image des horlogers des aventuriers de
la montre ton ici de se faire remarquer
et à ce petit jeu là les français sont
plutôt en bonne place
l'internet permet d'avoir une
communication beaucoup plus accessible
et le fait aussi que par internet on
peut se faire financer et il ya un
bouillonnement actuellement des jeunes
en faveur de la création d'entreprise
qui je pense aussi apporte beaucoup pour
l'enlever française ici les espaces son
petit est ouvert mais propice aux
échanges et reflète depuis deux ans le
renouveau de l'horlogerie française
philippe lebru créateur d'horloge depuis
plus de 20 ans en est convaincu
la position de l'horlogerie française à
bâle c'est une position qui est une
position
j'avais presque neuve avec une dimension
très créative avec la présence des
jeunes marques ici en 2018 qui sont au
nombre de 6 marques qui arrive à bâle
pour tester le marché et c'est le cas de
cette nouvelle marque bisontine venu
avec son tout premier modèle une pièce
médine france est très haut de gamme
vendu 58 mille euros c'est ici qu'on va
confronter au marché
via peut-être des clients via des
collectionneurs mais vient aussi des
distributeurs via des agents et c'est
eux qui donnent le coup qui donne
l'intention qui donne le reflet de la
perception du marché
pour ce premier produit un designer
ancien de chez peugeot
un ingénieur et un horloger sont à
l'origine de ce projet fou conçu et
réalisé dans le doubs à deux pas une
autre jeune marque avec un mouvement
suisse mais des aiguilles un bracelet ou
un assemblage médine franche comté et
puis une surprise avec le retour de
saint-honoré marque historique qui
cherche à toucher ici les
collectionneurs ça montre tour eiffel
innove jusque dans son bracelet c'est un
bracelet qui en polyuréthane et on a
intégré dans le poulet ritaine de la
poudre de la tour eiffel ce qui va
donner un aspect un peu métallisé du
bracelet et on est allé vraiment
jusqu'au bout du concept de la tour
eiffel en six jours au lieu de huit les
années précédentes il faudra convaincre
et se faire une place dans le monde des
géants suisses à la santé toujours
éclatante
[Musique]